this video has been kindly supported by
one trim
imagine a glorious future where humans
have overcome our present troubles
and we eventually leave this tiny planet
behind to live Among the Stars
in time our descendants spanned the
entire Milky Way countless trillions
living in Harmony from the galactic
center to the most distant spiral arm
one day a message arrives from outside
from another distant Galaxy another
distant cluster there is other life
other intelligence out there in the
universe
ideas are exchanged and science art and
philosophy prosper and eventually plans
are made in the darkness of
Intergalactic space the two great
civilizations will meet
many generations labor to build the
immense craft capable of traversing
great distances and many generations are
born live and die on the immense Journey
but after countless Millennia in the
inky Blackness the emissaries of the two
civilizations approach
two individuals float across the void
hands reaching out
they touch
and both vanish in a blinding Flash
[Music]
the great ships stand off from each
other staring in amazement
the civilizations are fundamentally
different and it is only now it becomes
clear
one is made of matter
and the other
antimatter and any contact leads to
annihilation
the ships Retreat into the darkness
knowing the true contact will always be
impossible
but how did it come to this how did they
not know about the difference in their
fundamental makeup they had shared their
science their mathematics and their
engineering surely this difference would
have been obvious but the scientists
knew better they knew that nature holds
on to its Secrets tightly they knew that
written into the laws of the universe
were rules that cloaked these secrets
rules fundamental to the functioning of
reality they knew that these rules were
built into many of the universe's
processes from the supermassive to the
microscopic and they knew that it was
these rules that had helped reality
freeze in the first billionth of a
second of time and behind them all they
knew that there was always one common
factor
symmetry
have you ever wondered how your brain
works or how the Earth formed or how
civilization began wondrium is the
perfect place for you and has been a
huge inspiration for both history of the
universe and history of the earth
wandrium used to be called Great Courses
plus which made the university level
lecture series and they've now expanded
to contain even more content from
travelogues and tutorials to long-form
documentaries wandrium is the best place
for high quality enjoyable content that
will make you smarter one great example
of this is the Theory of Everything
series by Don Lincoln an easy to
understand University level lecture
series and one I like to listen to to
get inspiration for the channel indeed
the two lectures on how symmetry Works
in physics were a huge help in making
this video it's exhaustive totally
understandable but never dumbed down it
is the best educational subscription
service out there hands down and they're
giving viewers a great offer of a free
trial so get the Fantastic education I
did by heading over to wandrium.com
forward slash history of the universe
thanks to wandrim for supporting
education on YouTube and sponsoring this
video
two great civilizations inhabiting two
distinct and distant regions of the
universe and yet we know their laws of
physics must have been the same then how
could they have failed to tell Mata from
antimatter to particles two atoms two
Intergalactic beings with opposite
electric charge in our patch of the
universe Mata is everywhere and
antimatter is rare but in their patch of
the universe the inverse must have been
true whilst we live by the light of a
star they lived by the light of
anti-stars whilst our ships were built
from atoms theirs were constructed from
anti-atoms
it would be understandable to think that
the laws of physics do not care about
the difference between matter and
antimatter
but that
is not quite true
we now know that nature does treat
matter and antimatter slightly
differently though these differences are
subtle and unexpected and related to one
of the deepest Concepts in all her
physics
what is symmetry we all know our first
perception of symmetry a mirror
Reflection from left to right armed with
such a mirror a child can sketch a
symmetrical shape with what is on the
left also seen on the right and vice
versa but looking in a mirror reveals
that this reflection runs deeply in
nature our faces and bodies are
symmetrical a right eye with a left a
left arm with a right nature makes many
uses of this mirror or bilateral
symmetry most mammals reptiles birds and
fish share this simple mirroring and
when the rules of Nature's symmetry are
broken such as the oversized claw of a
fiddler crab the appearance can be quite
jarring
symmetry is more than just reflection a
starfish builds itself using rotational
symmetry so when rotated its appearance
does not change a millipede uses
translational symmetry building its body
with identical chunks through these
symmetries nature is being economical in
design symmetry can also spark a deep
emotional response in human concepts of
beauty symmetry of appearance is
pleasing even though beauty is only skin
deep and inside we can be quite
asymmetrical and this appreciation of
symmetry has made its way into Art and
Design the great temples of the Ancients
in Egypt and Greece show Exquisite
symmetry as to more modern buildings
like the Taj Mahal and Arc de Triomphe
and many great artworks such as Da
Vinci's Last Supper and art in design
call on more than just simple mirror
symmetry as rotational symmetry can be
powerful from the rotating discs of the
pre-columbian Americas to the Exquisite
Islamic patterns adorning many mosques
across the globe indeed the massive
Pentagon home to the U.S Department of
Defense Bears its geometry in its name
symmetry is everywhere
but you might be wondering how this
relates to the fundamental rules of the
universe well our story starts as all
good stories do with a duel
at dawn on the 30th of May 1832 two men
met in a field outside of Paris
the cause of the conflagration is
unclear but rumor has it it was over the
affections of a young woman by the time
the sun was fully up that day
twenty-year-old mathematician Everest
galwa Lay Dying in the grass
the night before galwar had had a
premonition of his untimely death into
the early hours he had scribbled with
letters to friends and colleagues and
amongst these missives he'd pulled out
the last of his mathematical ideas for
in his short life galwar had brought
many new ideas to the world of maths and
Central to these was the idea of
symmetry the mathematics of symmetry was
not a New Concept ancient geometers had
realized that a rotated Circle remained
the same Circle and triangles squares
and pentagons appeared the same after
fixed rotations the galwar saw deeper
his Focus was algebra and more
specifically
polynomials polynomials are equations
with quantities to a power squares cubes
and higher for example 1 plus X Plus x
squared is a simple polynomial as is
three plus five times x to the power of
5 minus x to the power of seven such
polynomials are found across all of
science engineering economics and many
other fields other mathematicians had
scrambled to try and find algebraic
solutions to higher order polynomials
but galwa wondered if such an equation
existed for all polynomials one equation
to unlock them all yet instead of
discovering this ultimate equation he
actually showed it was a errand the
solutions just didn't exist and he
didn't do this by simply fighting
through the algebra but by looking into
the symmetries of the solutions he
realized the solutions to polynomial
equations were complex numbers each
being a point on the infinite complex
plane these points could appear as
shapes triangles pentagons or others and
shapes of course have symmetries they
can be reflected or rotated this was a
radical way of doing mathematics
translating equations into a geometric
picture and thinking about their
symmetries and since this work in the
early 19th century mathematical insights
into symmetries have grown and it has
since blossomed into group Theory the
study of groups of things that share
properties and symmetries modern
cryptology is underpinned by group
Theory but it is symmetry's impact on
science which has been the most
startling
and so as he Lay Dying In The Morning
Light galwar couldn't have known that
his scribbles would revolutionize
our universe
long before they met our two great
civilizations came into Contact radio
beams were fired Across the Universe
taking many millions of years to reach
their destination it was a slow and
cumbersome way of talking but this new
conversation with our distant neighbors
did at least work both civilizations
knew the laws of electromagnetism on
Earth the jiggling of atoms formed the
radio beam that carried the messages and
in the instruments of the aliens charges
jiggled as the messages arrived but
unlike on Earth these were
anti-electrons positrons dancing to the
beat of the radio waves
electromagnetism has a fundamental
symmetry if you swap all the positive
and negative charges the outcomes remain
the same this meant that the exchange of
radio waves alone between the two
civilizations could never tell Mata from
antimatter something else was needed
some crack in the tree of physics
and to understand why we need to start
our story almost a century ago
we need to start with a funeral
on the 1st of May 1935 an obituary
appeared in the New York Times this was
not unusual but the author famous
physics Professor Albert Einstein
certainly was
Emmy nurtur Einstein wrote had been the
most significant creative female
mathematical genius produced so far and
her insights had been necessary for the
deeper penetration into the laws
of nature
but what did he mean Emmy NATO was only
53 when cancer struck her and while her
name might not be as iconic today as
Einstein and the other old fathers of
physics her work was just as important
and nerta's Theorem has everything to do
with symmetry
key to this was one simple fact the
universe nature itself
is lazy with the coming of modern
science mathematics had steadily
replaced mysticism and geometric
symmetries had emerged from the
equations the spherical pull of Newton's
gravity resulted in spherical planets
and stars whilst the magnetic field of
an electric current was found to be
shaped like a cylinder these geometric
symmetries symmetries of shape were
pleasing to the eye but they were really
only skin deep there were other much
deeper symmetries lurking in the
mathematics of the universe as with any
story there were many potential players
but here we will focus on just two the
first was italian-born geosepi lodovicho
lagrangia better known as Joseph Louis
LaGrange and Irish mathematician William
Rowan Hamilton they share few
similarities in their lives the grandia
lived through the French Revolution and
was instrumental in bringing in the
metric system whereas Hamilton grew up
as a Wonder kid in Dublin almost a
century later but despite their
separation time their work dovetailed on
one key thing
reformulating the equations of Newton
and key to this Insight was the idea
that the Universe was lazy the Curious
concept of least action
indeed long before the French
mathematician Pierre de fermat had
proposed that light always took the
quickest path through any Optical system
imagine you are at the beach with waves
crashing into the shore often the
distance somewhere to the left you spot
Something In The Water a person is
waving no a person is drowning you have
to rush to save them
but which way do you go
you can run fast on the sand or you can
swim slower in the water dashing
straight to the shore and then swimming
out on the left will take too long
should you run along the shore and
minimize the time you've spent swimming
as you race the calculations in your
head you realize there is a better path
an optimal path you can run part way
along the beach and then dive into the
water this path will be the shortest
time between you and the drowning man
all other paths are longer fermat
realized that light traveling from one
place to another is like you on the
beach light takes the minimum time
between two points the bend path of
light as it refracts in water is just
like the bent path you take between the
land and the sea
but of course fermat only considered
this for light lagrangia and Hamilton
wondered if this notion could be
expanded across all of physics
and so hidden within the equations they
found that all nature somehow always
chose the laziest of options this might
sound strange why does the universe
function like this we still don't know
but it works to test this physicists
Define what is known as the action and
then consider every conceivable
possibility of a physical process indeed
there are an infinite number of
imaginary paths that light can take
between two points and for each of these
paths physicists can calculate the
associated action it seems that the path
where the action is most minimized is
always taken by Nature from Newton's
mechanics and Maxwell's electromagnetism
from quantum mechanics to Einstein's
general theory of relativity the
universe is laziness Reigns Supreme
and so the principle of least action is
written in the language of mathematics
and it is this that Emmy nurtur was
looking at when she noticed something
intriguing she realized that if the
equations possessed symmetries then this
would mean there would be special
unchanging quantities associated with
the symmetries this was an idea Central
to Modern physics the idea of conserved
quantities amounts that do not change
foreign
of these is the idea of conservation of
energy as school children we are told
that energy cannot be created or
destroyed only changed from one form
into another throw a board into the air
and the energy you expend is converted
into potential energy and then back into
kinetic start a fire and the fuel you
put in will equal the heat and light
that comes out the other side but that
is just the beginning physics is full of
conserved quantities and particle
reactions for every positive electric
charge that is created or destroyed and
equal but opposite negative charge is
also created or destroyed the total
charge of the universe therefore remains
a harmonious quantity of zero in a
collision between two objects the
quantity of momentum is conserved the
amount of momentum before the Collision
exactly matches that after the Collision
and so in terms of momentum the universe
once again appears to be harmoniously
balanced but why are these quantities
conserved other physical quantities mass
speed acceleration temperature are not
what makes these quantities special
what is it that separates the conserved
from the non-conserved
the answer is found by Emmy nurtur is
symmetry
imagine you have a physics experiment
set up on a table
something involving Springs and bouncing
balls you do your experiment and record
the outcomes how the various bits and
Bulbs move and interact then you push
the table 10 meters to the left and redo
the experiment of course moving the
table does not change the outcome of the
experiment the Springs stretch and the
balls bounce in the same way as before
the physics controlling the experiment
does not change with the change of
location and this means that the laws of
physics have a symmetry translational
symmetry to nurture the existence of
this symmetry have to mean that
something was conserved something didn't
change and from the mathematics
underlying the principle of least action
the mathematics of a lazy Universe she
showed that this conserved quantity is
just linear momentum meaning
translational symmetry implied the
conservation of linear momentum and
there were other symmetries hidden in
the mathematics meaning there must be
other conserved quantities
perhaps the most startling is the
implications of the Symmetry in time
performing The Experiment tomorrow
should give the same result as today and
it is the existence of this symmetry
that results in the most famous
Conservation law for symmetry in time
results in the conservation of energy
eminota had found that the equations led
to a remarkable conclusion tested
improved countless times in the century
since every conserved quantity in the
universe can be traced to an underlying
Symmetry and every symmetry results in a
conserved quantity
although they are not always
straightforward
many are buried deep in the equations of
quantum mechanics and whilst being
subtle their impact can be profound in
quantum mechanics things are described
by waves these Quantum waves are like
ripples on a pond but unlike Rippling
water Quantum waves are waves of
probability these waves share a lot of
similarities with the oscillations of
water as well as a wavelength that tells
you how long a wave is quantum waves
have amplitudes that tell you the
strength of that wave and like water
waves Quantum waves also have a property
known as their phase the phase is a
measurement of where in the cycles of
oscillations the wave is is the way even
a peak or in a trough but the properties
of an electron are independent of the
phase of its wave function they don't
change no matter how the phase May alter
and it is this symmetry this similarity
between the electrons that gives us the
conservation of electric charge other
symmetries in the mathematics of quantum
mechanics reveal even more esoteric
conservation laws barrier number lepton
number ISO Spin and strangeness to name
a few symmetries can even be found that
predict the fundamental forces gauge
symmetries for example result in gauge
bosons like the gluons that hold protons
and neutrons together through the strong
nuclear force the Symmetry between
protons and neutrons they're inherent to
similarity results in this Quantum force
and so when physicists unravel the
complex interactions of particles in the
Large Hadron Collider these Quantum
conservation laws rule Supreme
inevitably we should expect the Dual
fundamental interactions are totally
Bound by these fundamental rules
symmetries and conservation laws
operating hand in hand
everything in balance
and indeed they mostly are
but there are exceptions and it is these
exceptions that may have formed our
universe
[Music]
by the mid-20th century astronomers were
thinking about aliens giant radio
telescopes scanned the skies for any
faint beep from distant civilizations
some wondered just what we would say to
our ET cousins when we eventually made
contact but others worried about more
fundamental questions for example the
existence of antimatter beings
the problem was centered around telling
left from right this might seem trivial
but it is implicitly tied to Mata and
antimatter and the twin fates of our
doomed Intergalactic civilizations how
do you tell an alien the meaning of left
and right it's harder than you think you
can't send a picture as they would need
to know left from right to properly
reconstruct the image you can't refer to
trappings of civilizations such as
writing as they again would need a
reference you need to appeal to left and
right written in the fundamental
universe and you need to find a break in
symmetry that allows you to do this
you need to start thinking
about parity
in 1956 the universe was broken
in a laboratory in Washington DC
individual atoms of cobalt were spinning
in a magnetic field the experimenter
Chang Wu was watching patiently for the
Cobalt to change to undergo radioactive
decay and spit out an electron in
cooling the Cobalt atoms and placing
them in a magnetic field Wu could ensure
that they were all spinning together and
she could chart the directions that
electrons sped away from the Cobalt and
conservation of angular momentum meant
that they should be spat out from the
poles of the Cobalt some heading from
the Cobalt to North Pole and the same
number emitted from the South but as Wu
sat and counted the electrons
a disturbing pattern appeared instead of
a mix of electrons heading north and
south all appeared to be escaping from
just one side of the Cobalt atom it
appeared that this radioactive decay of
cobalt was not symmetric
but what did this mean so what if Cobalt
preferred to spit out electrons from one
side rather than another
well it all came down to a concept
called parity
up until the 1950s the conservation of
parity was core to fundamental physics
it meant that whatever was seen in a
mirror Universe was as real as the
physics that is seen in our universe
think of an atom when an electron jumps
from one energy level to another a
photon of light is emitted but in which
direction does this Photon flee you
should see half of the photons heading
to the right and the other half heading
to the left
but what if you view the atoms in a
mirror the mirror switches left to right
and vice versa but it also flips spins
from clockwise to anti-clockwise and
anti-clockwise to clockwise so the view
in the mirror is half the photons moving
to the left half to the right and so the
emission of a photon an electromagnetic
interaction obeys parity conservation
and the same is true for the
gravitational force imagine a planet
spinning and orbiting its star in a
clockwise fashion in the mirror universe
everything would slip to anticlockwise
motion at the quantum level there are
other forces that we need to consider
inside protons and to neutrons quarks
interact with quarks exchanging a small
particle known as a gluon this is the
strong nuclear force in action the force
that binds your Atomic nuclei together
both electromagnetism and the strong
force respect Quantum symmetries and
Quantum conservation laws
perfectly balanced
but there is another fundamental Force
the weak nuclear force
and the weak nuclear force seems
different
it is responsible for aspects of
radioactivity changing neutrons into
protons and spitting out electrons but
radioactivity is not so common in the
universe and it can seem that the weak
force is little more than a bit player
but it was this that all changed in 1955
when it was realized that the weak force
is the strangest of them all
particle physics had flourished in the
first half of the 20th century a flurry
of particle discoveries and Quantum
insights peeled away the world of the
very small and as patterns and pictures
began to emerge in the families of
fundamental particles the action of the
weak Force came steadily into Focus Chen
ning Yang and sung Dao Li were at the
Forefront of this effort as young
scientists at Princeton they began to
explore what nuclear experiments had
revealed they knew that the weak force
was responsible for some radioactivity
and that in these decays the great
Wolfgang poorly had predicted the
existence of a ghostly new particle the
neutrino and whilst no one had ever seen
a neutrino the conservation of energy
was sacrosanct and so it must exist Yang
and Lee were puzzled however over what
they saw they understood that
fundamental forces should conserve
parity but there was no smoking gun to
prove that the weak Force understood
that this was the rule and so an
audacious idea to cold maybe the weak
Force didn't conserve parity maybe it
wouldn't work in a mirror universe
whilst this sounded interesting as a
theoretical idea they needed an
experiment that could show that the weak
Force broke the universe and this is why
Wu had cooled her Cobalt atoms and
placed them in a magnetic field just
like a photon being spat out of an atom
the spin of electrons can be switched
between clockwise and anti-clockwise and
we should expect equal numbers of
electrons heading both northwards and
southwards
but of course this was not what Wu saw
in her sensitive experiment why would
electrons preferentially emerge from one
pole of a spinning Cobalt nucleus
the startling conclusion was that
Paulie's neutrino could only spin One
Way relative to its motion this meant
that there were only clockwise neutrinos
and by the conservation of angular
momentum they can only be emitted from
one Cobalt pole the electron from the
other a mirror view of the neutrino
would therefore appear to be spinning
anti-clockwise but such neutrinos simply
do not exist in our universe the mirror
version of the weak Force therefore also
does not exist in our universe the weak
Force violates parity
this discovery won Yang and Lee the
Nobel Prize in 1957. it was one of the
fastest ever awarded in physics much
faster than the 17 years that Einstein
had to wait Wu mysteriously missed out
but her name is written into the history
books of science for the experiment that
shook physics to its very core
the weak Force violating parity means
that neutrinos no right from left that
the universe itself somehow knows right
from left but the weak Force goes deeper
and in the following years other forms
of parity started to Tumble and it
turned out there were other symmetries
that the weak Force like to crack
and it is now that the mystery of matter
and antimatter can begin to be unraveled
[Music]
it was realized that order could be
restored to the Wu experiment if as well
as parity another transformation was
made if all the particles were
transformed into their anti-particles
known as a Charged conjugation
transformation the mirror view with the
spin anti-neutrino could occur in our
universe this double transformation is
known as CP for charge and parity and so
whilst the weak Force violated parity
perhaps it would obey CP but it didn't
take long for a new series of
experiments to show that this was also
not the case and this experiment
explored the weird behavior of particles
known as chaons
chaos and mesons a combination of one
quark and one anti-cork and neutral
chaons chaons without charge are a mix
of a strange quark and a down Quark but
there are two types of neutral chaons
one with a strange quark and anti-down
quark and another with an anti-strange
and a down Quark this peculiar situation
means that the two neutral chaons can
mutate into one another and a beam of
neutral chaons has to be considered a
quantum mechanical mix of the two
chaon's lifetimes are very short
decaying into lighter mesons pions in
about a billionth of a second and the
conservation of charge and parity
together means that there should always
be three pions in the Decay and so in
1964 an experiment was set up to explore
whether the combination of charge and
parity were actually conserved firing a
beam of chaons down a long tube
physicists counted the outcome of decays
almost all of the decays 499 out of 500
resulted in a burst of three mesons but
one in 500 resulted in only two pions
and it was here the universe was broken
once again charge and parity were not
conserved in the decay of Chaos
once again the result won the
experimenters Val Fitch and James Cronin
the 1918 Nobel Prize in physics but what
does CP parity violation really mean for
the universe
deep down it tells us that the laws of
the universe are different for matter
and for antimatter
thinking back to the meeting of the
great Intergalactic civilizations when
we began this journey this finally gives
us a solution to avert the disastrous
events that unfolded neutral chaos must
be considered a Quantum mix of matter
and antimatter and sometimes this
Quantum mix can Decay into electrons and
its antimatter partner the positron if
CP was conserved these decays should
produce equal numbers of electrons and
positrons but again Cronin and Fitch
found that CP was not conserved for
every 300 electrons produced into case
there were 301 positrons
and so all our Intergalactic descendants
needed to do was independently undertake
experiments with neutral chaos and they
would have known batter from antimatter
they would have known whether it was
safe to finally shake hands
whilst communication through
electromagnetism wouldn't help nor
discussions about gravity and the strong
nuclear force were this distant meeting
to occur we would be able to talk about
experiments with the weak nuclear force
and there would we find absolutes
but the question remains why does the
universe break these seemingly obvious
symmetries it would be a much simpler
place if the physics of matter and
antimatter were perfectly symmetrical
perfectly balanced
and indeed that is only the beginning it
seems the implications of CP violation
as it is known have much more
far-ranging consequences for the
universe and to truly understand this we
will need to return to the very
beginning of time when the intense
Fireball of the Big Bang
somehow
froze
[Music]
what is the ultimate goal of fundamental
physics is it to understand what
everything is made of to try and reveal
the origins of the universe
[Music]
to Einstein on his deathbed there was a
simple answer the Ultimate Prize was a
Theory of Everything a theory that would
finally unite all of the fundamental
forces
gravity electromagnetism the strong
nuclear force and the weak nuclear force
long the Holy Grail of quantum mechanics
and general relativity physicists have
taken steady steps in this Direction
first uniting the weak force with
electromagnetism in the 1960s the strong
force took more work but in Quantum
chromodynamics it too joined the party
and the ultimate aim the focus of
fundamental physics for more than a
century has been to incorporate gravity
a goal that physicists have yet to
definitively accomplish
but just how do physicists build these
theories of everything
once again guiding them are ideas of
perfection and symmetry
important Clues have come from high
energy experiments where particles are
smashed together at high speeds as the
energies of the interactions are
increased something peculiar begins to
happen to the fundamental forces they
begin to change their spots they alter
just how they operate between particles
they start to lose their distinct nature
and all begin to look
the same
let's consider electromagnetism and the
weak force in the universe today they
seem radically different with
electromagnetism connecting charges and
the weak Force being a form of
radioactivity electromagnetism is also
carried by the massless photon whereas
the weak Force uses three massive
particles the z0 and W plus and minus
but at higher energies this distinction
begins to blur and what is known as the
electro-week theory these seemingly
distinct forces are truly one single
force and so when the universe was hot
and young only this single Force existed
it was the cooling of the universe
through the big bang that broke their
Symmetry and made them distinct at
higher temperatures still the
distinction between Electro weak and the
strong force Fades away and it's thought
that at ultra high temperatures gravity
2 becomes indistinct this suggests that
the universe's birth
there was just one true Force the Super
Force and this Super Force was perfect
and symmetrical
the Bible begins in Genesis with the
line in the beginning was the word and
the Word was with God and the Word was
God
the Bible begins with Godly Perfection
that was ultimately corrupted modern
cosmology begins in a very similar
fashion
[Music]
beginning the universe was perfect and
symmetrical there existed the one true
Super Force and it reigned over all but
this Ultra hot Universe expanded and
cooled and fractures appeared in the
perfect symmetry of the cosmos out of
perfection imperfections began to appear
the individual forces separated first
gravity then the strong force as the
universe continued to cool the weak
Force separated from electromagnetism
but these separations as the universe
cooled were not uneventful as a force
went its own way the very nature of the
cosmos changed the universe before and
after the separation was distinctly
different it had undergone a phase
transition
as temperature decreases water freezes
into ice its symmetry is reduced in the
same way the separation of a fundamental
force is the universe cooled marked a
distinct fracture in the symmetry of the
universe cosmologists think that these
separations impacted the important
features of reality gravity separating
was at the Planck time when the universe
was about 10 to the power of minus 43
seconds old this is an age of the
universe we know almost nothing about
and until we can write down our grand
unified theory uniting the quantum realm
of gravity it may forever remain a
mystery but the separation of the strong
force is different it occurred much
later at about the age of 10 to the
power of minus 34 seconds and this is a
time that physicists think they have a
much better handle on for this is about
the time that inflation blew up the
universe
in the late 1970s Alan Guth was worried
about the cosmos he had started his
research career in particle physics
hunting for Grand unified theories as
well as hunting for a permanent position
as a professor but in 1978 he attended a
lecture that changed everything the
speaker was Robert Dickey an elder
Statesman of science being at the other
end of his career to Guth Dickey had
explored many Mysteries of the cosmos
and in this talk he was wondering just
why the universe appeared to be flat
rather than curved like a sphere or a
saddle somehow the birth of our universe
must have been fine-tuned selecting
flatness from all possible geometries
Guth was intrigued by this seeming
specialness of the universe and wondered
if it related to the fact a chunk of the
universe appeared to be missing a chunk
predicted once again by symmetry the
motivation was James Clark Maxwell on
the nature of electricity and magnetism
his equations were profoundly asymmetric
possessing electrical charges but no
magnetic equivalent all magnets we see
have a north and south many before gooth
had wondered where these magnetic
monopoles pure Magnetic North or South
Poles may be and so Guth decided that
they must be hiding
in the earliest moments of the universe
when it was hot and dense and seething
Guth suggested that the electromagnetism
was symmetric and that magnetic
monopoles were a part of the cosmic mix
of particles but as the universe
underwent an immense burst of expansion
doubling 80 times almost instantly the
magnetic monopoles were thinned out
enough so that there was only one per
observable universe after this period
known as inflation there wouldn't have
been enough energy in the universe to
create new magnetic monopoles they were
effectively lost never to be seen in a
Physics laboratory
so what happened to the universe during
its dramatic expansion
a background field of energy known as
the inflaton must have dominated the
density of the universe fell
precipitously as all particles were
robbed of their energy and the universe
became a frozen empty place but space
still seethed as the inflaton eventually
decayed and inflation came to an end and
so the energy of inflation was dumped
back into the universe reheating the
universe to many billions of degrees and
creating the matter that inhabits the
universe today but the magnetic
monopoles were long gone
but there was something strange in the
timing all this started around the same
time as a phase transition just as the
strong force separated was this just a
coincidence or was it the departure of
the strong force that ceded the inflaton
with energy we are still not sure indeed
our knowledge of the physics of this
Epoch is still a little hazy in parts
and so we cannot be sure that we have
found the true culprit of inflation
indeed some have also tied the inflaton
to the formation of the Higgs field the
field that gives particles Mass whilst
others have wondered if the inflaton is
just in early incarnation of today's
dark energy and so when the universe was
about 10 to the power of minus 12
seconds old and a Barbie 10 to the power
of 15 Kelvin all of the fundamental
forces had separated into the distinct
forms we know today but the action of
symmetry breaking still had one more
trick to play for it was in this Epoch
that barriogenesis occurred
this is the time when the super
fundamental particles quarks and gluons
began to condense into protons and
neutrons and the matter in the present
Universe the matter of you and me was
finally born
but a problem of symmetry remained
remember that the energy of the inflaton
was poured back into the universe after
inflation and this is the ultimate
source of matter and photons in the
cosmos today this reheating should have
equally produced matter and antimatter
one of the starkest asymmetries in the
universe today is the odd preponderance
of matter over antimatter Cosmic
searches have revealed a wealth of
matter across the cosmos and the barest
traces of antimatter as an example
scientists believe there is about one
part of antimatter to a quadrillion
parts of normal matter within the Milky
Way so where did this asymmetry arise in
the lifetime of the universe why is
there so much more matter it is thought
the answer is buried deep somewhere in
bariogenesis whilst we know and have
seen that the laws of physics can
differentiate between matter and
antimatter the degree of difference is
simply too small to account for the
difference in matter over antimatter and
so that still leaves us scratching at
the fundamental laws of the universe to
determine why there is any matter at all
[Music]
we can also estimate the degree of
matter antimatter asymmetry from an
unlikely Source the cosmic microwave
background these photons were emitted
when the Mata and antimatter in the
universe finally annihilated and for
every Proton or Neutron in the universe
today there are about a billion of these
Cosmic microwave background photons this
means that the Universe must have been
almost symmetrical for every billion
antimatter particles there must have
been a billion and one Mata particles
and it is this tiny difference that is
the source of all the universe's Mass
today
it is sobering to think that we are only
here because of this tiny asymmetry
but there is still one final mystery
that symmetry could help reveal
if symmetry is our true guide and
fundamental physics is purely
symmetrical there should be more than
just magnetic monopoles out there to be
discovered in the cosmos within a
supersymmetric theory for example for
every Quark there should be a symmetric
squawk and for every electron a
supersymmetric selectron this naming
process carries on throughout the
standard model from neutrinos to smuons
for fermions and hexenos to fotinos for
bosons a hidden supersymmetric Universe
of spartacles would be lingering just
Out Of Reach indeed supersymmetry is a
key part of many potential theories of
everything and scientists had long
expected to finally find evidence in the
Large Hadron Collider but hunts for
these mysterious particles in our
colliders have so far yielded none of
these supersymmetric candidates
always find are The Usual Suspects the
quarks and electrons of our universe
some physicists have claimed symmetry
has led us astray and we are on the
wrong path but for others symmetry is
simply too alluring and the hunt for
supersymmetry and the Super Force
continues we are almost at the end of
our journey and we have seen that
symmetry is clearly Central to our
understanding of the universe but it is
really the breaking of symmetries that
gives the universe its peculiar
personalities the fundamental laws and
the existence of matter truly arise from
cracks in perfection
but there is one final thing to consider
even though it feels like the breaking
of symmetries is something that happened
in the distant past our universe is
still expanding still cooling still
changing and we are mere footsteps into
the infinite future that lies ahead
and so hidden in energies well below our
experimental reach might yet be other
undiscovered symmetries and as the
universe continues to cool one day these
two might crack fracture and break
unleashing new forces and new phases
that could radically change the cosmos
our universe is March from Perfection to
Ultimate corruption might not yet
be over
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think thanks for watching and
we'll see you
next time
[Music]